好 把握哥出國前的時間
趕快來看籌碼
這個禮拜大家說
一天一個鬼故事
但是到了禮拜五
今天開開心心
是個神話的故事了
不過我們還是要來解惑
PCB的籌碼最近如何
似乎今天風吹到半導體
看來籌碼也是如此
昨天有大船特船
就CPU如果普及的話
就不要用到M9規格了
今天全部紛紛出來澄清
但是到底籌碼怎麼想的
再來的話 主力買什麼呢
封策股是一个很明显的族群
序长的主力投信都买的有谁
好 昨天我回去看筹码
怎么样怎么样
然后就看到台光店变成地板股了
今天已经准备好好的来抢一个
是不是
结果直接开高 开高就没得抢
好
因为这CGL报降规的鬼故事
可是外资送软了
所以今天其实他们的卖押都没了
对 今天都发谈
对 鬼故事是这样
第一 傳CPU技術導入
主機板對銅箔機板CGL規則取走
從M9變成M4
就不需要這麼高規了
不需要這麼高規
直接讓台光電台藥連貌就殺下來
可是呢
那法人就說
光通訊全面滲透到這些SKLout跟SKLout
這個範圖為時尚早
還早了
所以現在全面導入還太早
所以對CGL供應鏈影響有限
所以看起來沒什麼
業者也說我們那麼努力升級
怎麼可能現在就不搞了
重點他也講說
高階財務升級期日未變
M7-M9公不應求
看到公不應求
今天股價就回穩了
台光電是M9進入量產
藍牙M7-M8出貨增加
推薦M9是驗證
連貌持續擴充高階產品
所以這些新聞出來
他們的股價就只穩了
好 那這個外資對台光電
各位看一下目標價
昨天4000多
跌到4000多
結果目標價還是1萬
台光電這個右衣大盤
大摩是8400
台耀買進
平價買進3000
台耀跌到1200
3000是不是
然後這個大摩說2700
連貿是606
連貿不要接近電
对 那这个
这蓝电紧缩新机也还不错
是 这载板类的
载板类的
所以这看起来没什么问题
好 萤幕标价来说当然很远
可是我们需要看一下
筹码现在的状况
那看筹码
这些载板类的
其实筹码是没有很漂亮
板材类目前看起来
真的还好而已
对啊 你看主食主五
这个数字也没有很大
有点冷淡
所以這因為昨天的籌碼太差了
所以整個平均下來就沒有很漂亮
你看台光電它在那麼下面
對 那麼下面
籌碼很爛
因為主力大賣
它那種跌停一定是主力大賣的
那通常這種大跌
這種大跌的主力大賣
只要出量其實也不用太擔心
就變成有人在搶
對
好 那我們首先來看這個聯帽
那年貌今天受付黑K
昨天是跌停
然後今天這個小漲一點點
昨天主力大賣 外資大賣
那這個以前說年貌還蠻不錯的
其實它這波漲上來
在這邊算是一個高檔震盤整
那高檔震盤整
我們就要看一下主力這條線有沒有大殺那昨天看起來是有點恐怖不过今天就直稳了那未来就看这下通道有没有被跌破
假如没被跌破的话
我觉得还是一个盘整
尖点上应该是9月3号
两个礼拜前帮我们看的
那时候也是说它比较温
那尖点的筹码呢
其实长线看起来没有很漂亮
那尖点最近麻烦
怎么样怎么样麻烦
各位有沒有看到
他一直有注意
那假如一直有注意的話
那像這種股票大概
他就比較難大漲特漲
也沒什麼漲就在注意他
對 現在第六款了
因為現在監獄缺人
現在很缺 真的缺人
以前的星期很長
以前星期都10天12天
現在都是5天跟7天
以前都住6人房
現在都住單人大套房
所以隨便一點事情就注意你要不要來啊
缺人啊
很缺人喔
所以你看你看他出關兩天就被注意兩天
今天這個沒意外應該也會被注意啊
只要有量他就會被注意
所以呢在這邊會會呢可能四五天之後
五天之後又有可能就進關
那如果他有浪子回頭值得留意嗎
像這種很值得留意喔
像這種各位看一下
他現在是一個布林的大代官
那布林大代官呢就是喔
它的买位点很好抓
就上轨你就可以准备卖了
过没几天
它又要准备听牌又要被关了
那这时候只要跌到下轨
假如被关的话
跌到下轨又很值得买
好 来回区间操作的好标题
对 他现在是来回区间操作
蛮不错的
好 现在看下一个
台光店
可怜的台光店
我们的三本柱
现在剩台积店不错
台达跟台光真的有点辛苦
有点弱
那因为他们之前涨很多啊
是啦
那这波还原下来各位看
从这一段跌下来也是跌蛮多的
跌很多啊
六字头跌到四字头了
嗯
然后呢重点在这里
这边
昨天出了一个很大量
超大量
昨天出了很大量呢
就出现在地盘股
嗯
那今天就瞬间就止跌了
是
所以我们说地盘股
地盘股这个主力卖
你也不用烦恼
好
只要有出量呢
他就很容易这止跌
是
但是止跌之后呢
各位你就還要留意
止跌對這根量就有交代了
所以後面怎麼樣
要好好觀察
因為畢竟籌碼不好
但可以搶反彈
那反彈也彈了
所以大家要留意一下
也不能搶了
希望籌碼好轉才是
才是波段的王道
籌碼沒好轉錢不要買
好
來下一個
這個富強
最近投信其實一路加持上去
一路加持
但這個被外資到貨
外资跟投信对坐
所以最近的线型就没有很漂亮
然后在这边月线这边混
在月线混主力又卖的话
就比较辛苦一点
现在看这个见顶
GEO生
见顶就还不错
真的
各位看一下最近的筹码
这条线是往上的
微微往上
然后它是红买买卖
所以它的K棒也比较好一点
所以目前看起來見頂是有機會
溫溫漲還沒表態
但是成績非常好
對 好
再看下一個
我們進入到刺激組了
剛剛PCB感覺上比較溫和
今天一大排的封測之類的刷漲停
刷漲停 你看
先全系格基元町跟滑東漲停
然後他們的籌碼相對來講
比剛剛的載板類好一些比PCB好對 你看這邊紅的變多了紅的變多了這個我們來細看一下來細看首先看晶圓店
這個是網友的tone
到底你要混到什麼時候
一表態會不會又回去
我們看到這個
它的習性又怎樣
習性
習性就是喜歡紅K隔天配黑K
紅K配黑K
所以我们要看这个惯性有没有改变
改变没
要看礼拜一
礼拜一的假如是又红K的话
惯性改变了
有可能就发车了
来看下一个 矽隔
哇 这就漂亮了
漂亮
这是标准的开布林
标准开布林
因为这边是有压缩的
是 在那块也都开
有压缩的开布林很漂亮
算是这个开布林的第一根
第一根起来
這個假如禮拜一
又一根大紅K的話
非常確定
而且它在封測股裡面有指標性
對 好
這看起來不錯
看起來不錯
像今天大買的
大買的叫做大摩
大摩比較長
小摩比較短
大摩座比較長
所以有機會
而且它在這邊其實沒有漲太多
大家可以留意看看
再看下一個
超風
超風就真的好溫吞
超風也是很溫吞的
記憶體相關
不過今天也是一樣
有開布林
開布林啦
對 凡是開布林沿上軌
它的股價就會活潑一點
是
所以這個我們就可以來留意
因為最近連五紅
對 而且是壓縮的窄貸款開的
沒錯 窄貸款
貸款算蠻窄的
只要窄貸款
這個突破上遠的看起來就
主力就會來看
大家看一看也比較有興趣
因為這個慣性改變了
以前都是到了上通道就回來
上通道就回來
中有一天會突破的
就在這天突破了
所以行情看起來
對這個是有機會的
新權也很兇
連續兩天漲停
對啊 也是一樣
出量所漲停
你看之前的是到上通道就下來
上通道就下來
那今天不一樣了
所以慣性不一樣
慣性改變
凡是慣性改變
代表這行情
可能还会持续下去
是 好 因为封册我们一直认为
明年成长性比今年还要好
那看来有发动的味道
对 没错
因为只要大家一起动
就是好事情
所以我们就期待这些
这个封册一直走
然后后面就被关了
那我们就好买一点就出现了
好 借由发奖状也看一下
因为之前刚刚凯哥有讲了
全新有的桃园分点是不是
是不是走掉了呢
之前有买
好 因为这边有讲
所以全新從小哥講到現在也長了三勝
還有華星光
那時候也說要救救他讓子回頭
回頭了
回頭啊 很漂亮
現在談起來了
你看這個
先講全新
怎麼樣桃園分點
桃園分點最近有再出拖一些
真的喔
因為漲多了就會賣
習性就這樣
那全新呢
一樣
他也是有儲資的問題
漲多了也是容易被關
那容易被關
像全新只要一回黨
像这种月线网上的
一回挡到月线附近的
都是好买点
所以你看到月线附近的
到间又喷出去
那华星光呢
它是一个大带宽的盘整
那目前呢
它也是很容易被处置
你看最近
这个出关5天就被关
出关5天被关5天
它现在就5天关5天
这个出关
在外面
这个还蛮好玩的所以一樣到了下通道勇敢买进到了上通道差不多了获利了结所以这个很好玩
很容易玩 如果了解它的话
真的要了解它
而且这个你要看布林通道
你不要看均线
看均线在这档股票会巴来巴掘
布林通道在这一档特别好做
这也是长期对每一档股票的观察
是
最后来看一下主头连买
對 最近這邊的籌碼就非常漂亮
這是主力買這個
頭信也在買的
你看這主石柱這邊全部都紅的
這邊全部都紅的
可是很多都是金融股
比較穩定的股票
因為頭信前陣子剛剛也聊了
都在買金融股
現在風向要稍微吹了
有點變了
要跑到黑暗了
這個主力連買
像可成8天 低金15天
這邊籌碼都很好
这些全部都好的
这边全部都好的
全部都好的
那全部都好的
我们就来看几檔
现在来看富士达
这虽然是比较高价股
但散热相关今天很强
今天高丽富士达
双红都很强
所以富士达还不错
前部有稍微
让子回头一点点就涨上去
最近在盘整
主力都没掉
只要主力没掉的话
回到月线都是不错的卖点
那最后一个我们就看可诚
你的爱股
真的很想问你
他们到底要干嘛
一直收库长股
一直收
然后到底收那么多
那股本越来越小
到底想干嘛
股票全部都在老板身上
到底想做
都在公司身上
对不对
哥去打听一下吧
这个股价
这个股票都在公司身上
它会越来越安定
越来越安定
那之后它有AI的题材
真的
真的有
有啦
它跟NV不是有那个吗
之前传过订单
可是就热闹一下又冷掉
热闹一下就回来
熱鬧一下回來
回來就實施庫長股
那現在實施庫長股一段時間
它還真的很認真在賣
所以智長股票
我覺得它的籌碼越來越安定
終有一天會噴出的
目前以股息來說也不錯
因為可誠前一陣子有傳出
跟NVIDIA的合作
本來以為就是要發動的意思
但它又回歸成績
又回來
對 我們就也是繼續看下去
對 這檔很好玩
我覺得這檔這是純股族最愛的標的
因為純股族很怕標股
標了之後就想賣
這檔不太標了
很牛啦
我覺得也很好奇
也許之後就會再公布一些
公司新的規劃了
好 非常謝謝小哥
好 各位來幫我們做見證
PCB當然我們都知道產業的前景很好
不過呢
可能有些PCB是今年的成長率很高
明年也許在高積極下
會比較有所疑慮
所以現在看來
主力的資金在這一塊是
跌升了會去搶喔
但是漲上來的話
可能也會順勢做一些調節
這個族群目前籌碼是漲這樣子
大家可以參考看看
但是錢有跑到哪裡去
今天封測股雖然很多當帳廳
但看來有些事剛開始叫做
慣性改變了
之前都在橫盤整理嘛
突然往上突破了主力的買盤力道加大
整體族群開始熱起來了
這是值得留意的
以及剛剛也幫大家分享了
主力投信都在買的
投信確實有從金融股開始慢慢布局到AI股去囉
這樣的動態都值得您做籌碼的留意喔
好 今天是星期五的晚上
非常謝謝三位的被您來到現場
這禮拜我們歷經過量極度的縮
量又開始放大
下禮拜有連假我們不要急
這四天我們看一下
高速低進可能會是一個好的策略
就期待接下來長假過後的光輝第四季喔
那也希望今天理財達安秀
帶你投資有幫助喔
下週再會了 掰掰